and there's a human being in the
mirror and that human being is
trying and they've been there a long
time and they've been waiting for you to
wake up and to see them they're tired of
your constant negativity they're tired
of you beating them down they need you
to be more encouraging they need you to
be more celebratory they need your
support and when you finally wake up and
create a moment with
yourself every single morning where you
look yourself in the eye and you see
yourself and you forgive yourself and
you honor yourself and you say I believe
with this gesture in
you it is this remarkably deep and
spiritual feeling of connection that
you've been longing for for a very long
time